two thieves inside this smoke shop one
outside holding the door and the shop's
owner just about to jump into action
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
now the video we're about to show you is
really making waves online but we do
want to warn you it is violent and
disturbing
all right take the money in it i keep
the coins i need points
bro okay
[Music]
yeah it is tough to watch police tell us
this happened on wednesday and they
arrested two juveniles in this case and
one as you can see there was taken to
the hospital after being injured
victoria saha spoke to the man who saw
stabbing the accused thieves and she
joins us now live with what he had to
say victoria
yeah denise the owner of smokestream
says he noticed one person holding this
door open then two people with ski masks
came in that's when he noticed there was
trouble
smoke strum is the pride and joy for
owner johnny newen this store is my life
i worked i worked hard to get everything
i have and he says he wasn't about to
let these two thieves take anything away
they walked in on wednesday afternoon as
new and was working at his smoke shop at
first i thought they were just normal
customers then i realized they had
like ski masks on you hear him asking
why they're wearing the masks why are
you guys wearing masks like though you
will notice around this moment newin is
reaching for something near the register
i had to assume they had a firearm
so i just wanted to make sure that
i could protect myself did you see it
no i did not see it but i couldn't take
that chance one person tries running off
with the tip jar another jumps over the
counter this is when the owner attacks
newman says he believes he stabbed the
robber seven times and the video backs
that up i didn't think he planned on
getting stabbed that day obviously but
if you try robbing a store
you're taking that risk
right like this is this is a small
business obviously after the stabbing
newman dragged the boy out of the store
and called for police and
this paramedics my idea
for business owners a situation like
this is always a worry so we talked to
security expert jonathan alvarez and
what he thought of the situation i
wholeheartedly
agree with defending yourself and having
that ability to defend yourself and your
family and others um but if it's just
items that are replaceable at the end of
the day it's just just let them take
what they what they need to take
according to metro the two seen in this
video are teen boys again new and did
stab the young man seven times his
condition is unknown but newand says
that he was talking up until um help
came and newton also says he will be
from now on buzzing people in and he
says he'll be arming himself as well
victoria saha live local now
victoria thanks for that the store owner
in this situation stayed remarkably calm
from beginning to end now if you find
yourself in a robbery the department of
public safety says you should stay calm
and do not resist
follow the robbers directions but don't
offer more than what they're asking for
make mental notes of the robber's
appearance then after it's over go to a
safe location and call police